non maman c'est samedi soir merde mais
dis donc Jésus
c'est quoi ces gros mots là
et
Sam j'ai juste 12 copains qui attendent
que j'arrive au restaurant et c'est le
moment que tu choisis pour me faire une
scène tu sais ses copains Jean Thomas
Mathieu
Simon Pierre c'est celui qui ressemble à
une fille là
je suis un peu la grappe on est en l'an
33 ce serait peut-être temps d'avoir une
vision un peu large toi et papa vous
avez pas hésité à faire une PMA avec
l'aide de Dieu pour arrondir les fins de
moi donc si ça savait je sais pas trop
comment ça serait pris alors voilà et
sur Twitter des internautes n'ont pas du
tout validé ce sketch mais en général je
calcule pas mais là vraiment c'est trop
abusé cette pièce de théâtre est juste
sur prétexte pour chier à la gueule du
christianisme j'avais rien contre Paul
Mirabel mais là il me déçoit fort les
boomers bourgeois qui sont morts de rire
devant le niveau zéro de l'humour voilà
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a des il y a des
gens qui ont été choqués qui a été
choqué qui n'a pas été jugé non pas du
tout
Isabelle Nanty on a pas trouvé ça pas
drôle en revanche parce que c'est
peut-être pas drôle mais en revanche je
suis pas du tout choqué je trouve ça
très bien que ça existe heureusement que
ça existe c'est la force de notre pays
que ça puisse exister et ça devrait
pouvoir exister pour toutes les
religions donc moi ça me choque pas du
tout et ça ne me branle pas ma foi non
plus voilà Béatrice de choqué alors je
suis pas choqué par le sketch je suis
choqué par le fait que je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec Géraldine sur le fait
qu'il faut pouvoir se moquer des
religions ce qui me choque c'est que
c'est toujours sur le catholicisme voilà
c'est toujours sur cette religion là
parce que évidemment c'est celle qui sur
laquelle il y a le moins de conséquences
et à force c'est un peu
pourquoi je dis ça
je vous le dis les Inconnus ils ont fait
des sketchs
quand ils ont fait le sketch la chanson
Jésus est [__]
mais il faut être honnête ils auraient
pas osé moi ça me choque pas il y a pas
de délit de blasphème
dans les autres journaux je peux vous
dire il y a plein de parodie sur
d'autres religions je suis pas là là
dessus je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
même pas du tout
parce qu'il y a un truc qui m'a choqué
tu dis parce qu'on sait qu'il y a pas de
conséquences tu les entendre que dans
les autres religions il y aura des
conséquences si jamais
politiquement correct deuxièmement parce
que 90% catholique
c'est pour ça et puis c'est tout bah non
et puis la la dernière chose enfin
pardon mais effectivement c'est pas très
drôle mais ce qui me choque moi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on met tout au même
niveau c'est-à-dire que le gamin qu'on a
reçu ici et que toi qui est dans une
église ça choque les gens et il prend
les mêmes messages audio 15 sketch comme
ça c'est pas la même chose que c'était
la nettoyer les vitres avec le courant
aussi le toit ou le Coran c'était une
horreur ça c'est un sketch drôle ou pas
drôle on peut pas mettre tout au même
niveau comme le font les gens sur
Twitter
je suis extrêmement choqué et ce qui
s'est passé est très grave et je
m'étonne du nombre de noms pour moi
c'est le dévoiement total du service
public
c'est du déshonneur mais arrête de dire
non mais non mais là non mais là tu nous
rends pas ça je te dis la vérité là en
disant ça tu nous demandes pas service
tu dis des conneries tu nous rends pas
service ce sketch non non mais en
parlant du service public du service
public qui fait n'importe quoi tu sais
même pas que c'est sur France 2 arrête
de dire des conneries sur TF1 il aurait
de service public
mais n'importe quoi non mais là là en
fait parce que j'ai parlé du service non
pas du tout il veut
arrête non mais là on a vu c'est que ADS
t'inquiète tu seras là demain on a la DS
arrête de sucer
que ce soit sur le service si c'est pour
dire sur le service public franchement
je te jure c'est insupportable parce que
c'est j'ai un truc que j'ai fait et tu
vas être dans mes dans mes patins arrête
un peu
non mais arrête un peu arrête de parle
pas de service public d'ici je te
souhaite ou pas je suis choqué on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas sur une
télévision publique
comme eux
comme les journalistes on se parle tant
guignol je te jure c'est un animal mais
je t'aime beaucoup mais là
c'est pas ton avis tu essaie de faire
plaisir
à Cyril tu as un ESC toi un énorme
[__]
Gilles vraiment et vous dites à Béatrice
qu'elle a pas les bons arguments vous me
dites à moi c'est pas la même arguments
mais c'est pas mal on est choqué
je te parle pas est-ce que tu sketches à
choqué bien sûr c'est honteux ce sketch
on n'a pas le droit de se moquer comme
ça de la religion catholique
mais ça tu peux le dire mais c'est pas
le support le problème c'est pas le
support là je dis ce que je veux Mathieu
arrête franchement tu as un nièce je me
tais non mais alors est-ce que le sketch
a chopé ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non parce que ça je peux comprendre
qu'il soit choqué donc vas-y je suis
extrêmement choqué par ce sketch qui se
moque d'une manière
ignominieuse de la religion catholique
qui pourfend les valeurs bien sûr que ce
n'est pas un délit bien sûr que la
liberté d'expression et s'accro-sainte
en France mais ça ce n'est pas drôle
c'est choquant c'est fait pour faire mal
et c'est fait pour faire mal aux
catholique je suis désolé il y a
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux
qui le pense c'est son avis il a le
droit de la limite non mais plein de
gens sur les réseaux étaient choqués
Cyril mais que tu commences à vous allez
dire que je suce les réseaux que je sais
pas quoi et tout ça je m'en fous je vous
donne mon avis ça sur le service public
ce sketch c'est une onde voilà arrête
ce qui nous rend pas service
un peu à la rescousse si vous me
permettez de Béatrice parce que je
trouve qu'on a un petit peu laissé
tomber
je veux être honnête idéologiquement et
je pense que effectivement elle a
complètement raison il y a malgré tout
aujourd'hui des skate qui sont plus ou
moins accidentogène suivant les
religions et je trouve que ne pas être
non c'est pas vrai je suis désolé il y a
des religions on peut plus s'attaquer à
des religions et on peut plus blesser
sur les vaccins bah oui alors là sans
aucun problème dans la gueule comme ça
donc il y a pas de problème mais en fait
je trouve que oui c'était malhonnête de
faire comme si c'était pareil pour toute
la religion ça n'est pas pareil pour
toute la religion
en tout cas pour moi quand on voit ces
images c'est pas dégradant ça dégrade
pas la religion c'est pas irrespectueux
par Elise Lucet qu'interpelle le pape
qui avait interpellé le pape à l'époque
comme si c'était pas ça non mais c'était
son pote de 6e on est où là donc c'est
pas irrespectueux moi je trouve que
c'est un sketch personnellement je
trouve ça très drôle ben voilà en fait
c'est une famille en l'an 33 et en fait
on a trop de pause
[Rires]
sur la religion là c'est à votre
historique c'est drôle c'est bon et
quand on se détendra quand il y aura
plus des gens comme Gide et ben
peut-être que on fera plus on se
rapproche pas mal de gens qui qui sont
fous de moi Gilles est un LCDs c'est
quoi un lèche Q doublé d'un [__]
ensuite non mais il faut dire la vérité
ce sketch je pense que personne ne le
trouve drôle on l'appelle c'est ici
personne n'a rigolé dans le prime ils
sont obligés de rajouter des rires en
post-production parce que personne ne
rigole c'est très drôle moi d'accord
Géraldine ça l'a fait rire et ensuite je
pense qu'il ne faut pas plaisanter avec
leur religion je pense que c'est
personnel tu le sais et ce qui m'énerve
là-dessus ils font pas ça pour être
personnel tu l'as dit oui c'est pas
public la religion
le sacré à l'église et à la synagogue il
a la mosquée et même le sacré il est en
soirée non mais sacré soirée mais ce qui
m'énerve c'est que ils font pas ça pour
être drôle ils font ça au nom de la
liberté d'expression et qu'en fait la
réalité c'est capable de blesser des
gens ça ne fait rire personne donc
beaucoup mon grand parce que dans chaque
émission tu passes ton temps à dire
qu'il faut être libre de choisir sur
votre machine
pour la liberté mais en revanche la
religion faut jamais toucher à aucune
personnelle je suis d'accord avec moi je
suis catholique ça m'a fait rire pardon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
tous les cas ça m'a pas choqué je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec Guillaume
[Rires]
c'est oh ça n'a rien à voir avec cette
et on sait tous battus pour la liberté
d'expression on était tous Charlie je
suis désolé on peut rire de la religion
et heureusement c'est ça et franchement
j'étais la première à être choqué parce
qu'elle avait fait Benjamin parce que ça
n'a rien à voir c'est du il y a du
blaster interpelle le pape comme si
c'était son pote de 6e ça ça me choque
plus parce que voilà c'est pas son pote
évidemment et donc c'est un ça peut
passer pour un manque de respect donc ça
c'est plus choquant mais là franchement
heureusement qu'on peut encore faire ce
genre de ski Bernardo sur ses news aussi
ils appellent Bernardo parce que vous
n'avez pas parler depuis le début
j'attends vous me donniez la parole
bravo bravo j'attends que vous Daniel la
parole vas-y mon chéri non je disais que
sur cnews aussi le dimanche matin il y a
des émissions religieuses tiens à
signalé non moi je suis je suis croyant
ben oui c'est important de le dire je
suis croyant je suis en forme de cœur
ADS et
et moi je suis croyant j'étais en forme
de cœur etc je ne suis pas choqué du
tout c'est de l'humour heureusement
qu'en France on est cette liberté là
justement aussi avec cette religion
alors on va reconnaître s'il te plaît
non à 65% oui à 34% donc il y en a qui
ont été choqués 34%